foreign
[Music]
it's a hard thing to explain but it set
me into a mindset of the seriousness of
the material it's like these
environments are talking to me
[Music]
[Music]
this movie looks completely different
than any other film about this subject
matter aesthetically and also the
journey that Peter went on the idea is
that in every frame it's evocative and
informative trying to capture the
beautiful and the brutal and the
Landscapes of Louisiana it really is an
energy
you can really feel it
[Music]
Naomi has done a brilliant job of
recreating the reality of that time from
building the horse and buggy carts
recreating slave Shacks to building the
railroad site to building the
battlefield on and on and on hello Naomi
she's so passionate you give Naomi
Direction she'll build you the world the
windmills pump water which then goes
into the cistern which then feeds the
the steam cars when they come through I
build in shots lighting when it's
interior I build in a lot of stuff that
the cinematographer can then discover
he is my slave
in my defense
he has become my salvation I am
completely motivated by the way that the
story is going to be received by the
world but I measure my own success on
whether it shoots well
[Music]
for me as a cinematographer I search for
something extraordinarily real Antoine
and I belt that what had been
accomplished in the past with color is
something we didn't want to repeat so we
looked for a palette that was black and
white yet allowed certain colors to come
out of it so it's not a completely black
and white but it's a heavily desaturated
feel a grittier feel the desaturation of
the film and the look that was really
critical for capturing the brutality
Peter's constantly on the run so his
camera is virtually always the same
always in motion
[Music]
the scenes in which we're shooting
dodian
we slowed it down and we're more stable
so that you have the fixture in a more
structured background for her in
combination with the race is taking
place between Peter trying to avoid
basil and his men who are hunting him
down
brother
Twila
[Music]
well I've always been a history buff
I've always been interested in the
origin of things why things are the way
they are Francine kept it honest as far
as the Wardrobe and the look
there were Fabrics back then they were
called negro cloth now called Eisenberg
and it is a rough grain very scratchy so
I like the fabric but let's get
something that is a bit more comfortable
and that's where I really wanted to go
with cotton and linen blend Peter was
running from these vicious people who
are trying to capture him to go on that
Journey with him we actually had 70
shirts
7D trousers all of these things had to
have a multiple of 70 with his first
outfit
the first time those iron collars got
put onto my neck it was like
comprehension slightly beyond your
rational mind where things come through
that you haven't thought about it was
like stuck on my neck for probably 15
minutes people were running around
looking for a key to get it off of my
neck but
Peter was being beaten while he had it
on his neck
to see my journey through this industry
as a black woman and a black American
woman I think my ancestors would be very
proud obviously we still deal with
things today but I think part of healing
is trying to find some truth in it and
so that's my journey it's the journey
that all my crew came to join so
hopefully that's what we did
[Music]
foreign
[Music]